[Music]
it was cool it was cool a lot of a lot
of the fans connected with the music
roddy rich and the weeknd tied for the
most
nominations at the american music awards
of 2020
with eight nods each being able to be
spiritual support for a community and
the young people is always a good thing
so it's a blessing roddy rich dominated
the billboard charts this year
spending 18 weeks atop the hot 100
that puts him among the 10 most popular
artists
to grace the list in billboard's 62-year
history
alongside artists like drake usher and
the beatles
the box scored rich his first number one
on the billboard hot 100
chart and over 250 million views
on youtube can't give your secret out
man
roddy you got something what are you
doing what are you hooting oh what i'm
just saying
is that what is that no no i'm dripping
social media helped catapult the box to
become
one of the top memes on tick tock with a
whopping 2.1 million videos
created on the platform i just made a
rolly playing like a landing strip
[Music]
both roddy rich and the weeknd have
taken social media by storm solidifying
their success the two-time ama winner of
the weekend
topped the billboard charts in 2020 with
his hit song
blinding lights
the song has inspired over 1.5 million
video creations on tiktok
and launched the blinding lights
challenge with
celebs like jessica alba jenny mccarthy
and nicole shersinger getting in on the
fun
the weekend followed the challenge with
a virtual concert on tick-tock
that drew over 2 million viewers and
raised
350 000 for the equal justice initiative
[Music]
both musical heavyweights will compete
for the 2020
ama artist of the year against justin
bieber
post malone and taylor swift
[Music]